vous avez une mère de famille qui arrive
à ce qu'un enfant qui a 42 fièvre depuis
48 heures et ben la maman elle est
anxieuse elle est inquiète pour son
enfant et ça se comprend et quand la
pharmacien lui répond bah non je suis
désolé madame j'ai pas d'antibiotique à
vous donner en France en 2022
ça pose un problème
[Musique]
depuis qu'il y a une rupture nationale
en fait sur la motricité c'est-à-dire
donc depuis mi-décembre et qu'on a eu
les autorisations par les agences
régionales de santé et bien on est passé
du production qui était de 0 puisqu'on
n'avait pas besoin d'en faire à une
production donc qui est de 5 6 voire
8000 gélules jours
[Musique]
vu la demande on essaye de faire au
mieux donc de faire des heures
supplémentaires dans la mesure du
possible je pense qu'on a des capacités
de tenir par la résistance physique de
mes collègues et parce qu'elles sont
motivées parce que c'est leur métier
c'est notre cœur de métier quand même
d'être au service de la santé publique
on est capable de tenir plusieurs mois
le temps que l'industrie pharmaceutique
puisse refourir correctement la France
là actuellement je suis en train de
conditionner les gélules donc je
répartis la poudre dans l'ensemble des
gélules donc là j'ai 90 gélules à
conditionner donc je répartis en
m'assurant de la bonne répartition de
poudre
[Musique]